you ripped my drip uh this one's really
involved kind of goes back to
rip my drip is i get it it's bad for
their clothes right
[Laughter]
i didn't know you're from you're from
you know listen to my god i don't
want to know this i gotta do that one
year of community college
with my trip
[Music]
yo what's up king and the sting this is
mike here at my bike shop in downtown
denver colorado called bike shop on 21st
and curtis
this is rip my drip go ahead and check
this out it's a
5 farm straight from the 90s edition all
right vintage
all vintage we got the movado one we got
the eddie bowers and we got the
timberlands on
all right now this special shirt right
here it's got a little hidden pocket
right here
for your lighter whatever you need they
don't make them like this anymore look
at the cut
see that cut see how it hangs down i
don't make them like this anymore man
this g
[ __ ] all right i'll check these out all
right this might rip my drip shoes right
here
now these are 1996 packer reebok
collaboration for the 1996 all-star
nba game can't excuse just
come on bro come on and join me next
time for a little bit of
tune my room where you guys help me you
know add additions to my room and stuff
like that i got a collection upstairs
before we go though hold up we got that
25th anniversary
vintage 1990s disney original come on
bro
that's part of my collection i got it in
the beginning i didn't think it was that
bad it's getting worse and worse
like incredibly quickly
at the beginning i'm like okay you know
i was like all right well he just looks
like he shops at t.j.maxx probably has
the old chicken i mean
25th anniversary disney world thing i
mean there's just
no excuse for that there's no excuse for
that
though the whole outfit is just the hot
mess man 1996 was the best year of his
life because 25 years ago was
when the package was like a shirt that
like you know making a murderer on
netflix
yeah a shirt that like a member of the
family wears to court
you know they come in like a disney
shirt and the lawyer's like yeah we can
you do anything else
do you have a partner yeah they're like
you wear anything else and he's like
yeah let me get this fat farm button up
on
you know what just leave just wear that
just to the disney shirt yeah that fat
farm uh denim whenever you see somebody
in a denim shirt you go this is
someone no i like denim no i like it
yeah i like denim
you can't do denim with denim with jeans
though well you can't do a texas
i just feel like i feel like when i see
a big guy maybe it's me but when i see a
big guy in a denim jacket
i go there's a guy that needs a cop
present to see his daughter
there's a guy who's visitational rights
with this yeah yeah that
that's a problem am i considered a big
guy no like i'm talking about fat guy
denim jacket oh
gotcha do you like denim jackets i love
denim i can't maybe i should get into
denim
i think you look sweet in denim i might
you know too many people have dissuaded
me from denim
yeah you gotta hang out the right people
man so i could pull off you think a
black denim jacket [ __ ] yeah you look
sweet in that
wow yeah you'd look sick in that all
right you know i might be doing that
the video did you did as the influencer
i mean i looked
great it didn't look bad no i looked
what video was it i looked [ __ ]
amazing
what's the title of it uh
uh i don't know if it's a title i mean
there is a title
i don't i don't remember it it's on my
youtube or something it's how long ago
was yeah i mean i looked dope i looked
dope as [ __ ]
dude look how dark i look i looked
a lot of these kids are giving out like
bottles of water and [ __ ] to homeless
people
was it a honey dijon at least yeah it
was no it was nice
it was like a uh i don't know it was uh
like a straight mustard there's like a
stone ground
that's not bad not bad but i that babe
hoodie man when i put it on dude
a black guy came up to me and babe he
goes you look fly as [ __ ] right now
and dude i've never felt better in my
life he goes the fit is fresh
and dude there was like little kids
looking at me like [ __ ] yeah man like
stay cool dude hypebeast i didn't know
this there's hypebeasts that are like
four
like oh yeah hypebeasts are like literal
children that are like
in [ __ ] vape yeah man they're like 12
years old in baby it's real
they've been waiting for like nine hours
to get a shirt so they can resell it
but it's a community like i feel you'd
look cool in a black denim jacket and
some
like uh dad yeezys yeah i might do that
dude
i don't give a [ __ ] maybe i'll get you
those yeezys just as a friend
i appreciate what size should you wear
13. you wear 13 13.
so do i you can i i got you i'll do it
i'm going back to vape i think i'm going
to go back to get another i want another
hood
and they're not cheap they're like 450.
they're not cheap and you know what's
crazy the hood is so big
then it looks like you have the mouth on
it yeah it's good and it's got this big
alien in the back i mean
dude but you i don't know it's like you
put one of those on you're like oh yeah
[ __ ] it i could be this person now
it's kind of cool but i don't feel like
you can drop an emboss yeah you're like
i could just say the n-word and
drive around it's going to be like when
christol uh told rappers not to drink
the ceo told them not to drink it
they're going to ask you to stop wearing
it because it's a bad look for them
right
right they're like gucci
whole new audience it's for well vape is
really just for like
[ __ ] fat hypebeasts like that's what
babe is for it's like for crazy
it's real yeah out of shape boys yeah
it's like not you know
[Music]